-Our guest tonight
is a co-host of "CBS Mornings,
host of the SiriusXM show
"Gayle King in the House,"
and the editor-at-large
of Oprah Daily.
The winter issue
of "O Quarterly,"
which features
the 25th anniversary
of Oprah's Favorite Things,
is on stands now.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Gayle King,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-God, there's people!
-I know.
-It's so nice to see people!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God, Seth.
I don't know about you.
I was just saying
to your team backstage
it's so nice to have people
in the house.
I'm so glad to see you people.
And then you go through
what to wear.
-Yeah.
Because do you dress up?
Do you dress down? You know,
my makeup artist said to me,
"Could you please
wear something fun
instead of what you normally
wear? 'Cause Seth is fun."
So I tried to be
sparkly and fun.
-I'm very glad you wore
your Seth clothes.
-These are my Seth clothes.
-And you did me the great
courtesy of being a Zoom guest
in the time
where we weren't having guests.
So it's so nice to see you again
in person.
-I feel that, too.
-And do you feel like things --
I know you're in a new studio.
-We're in a new studio
in Times Square.
We like that.
-That's great.
-There's a new co-host.
Nate Burleson. Like him.
-He's wonderful.
He's a super-sharp guy.
-He is. He's very dapper.
He dresses very well.
He's very smart.
We're having a good time.
But I feel that, you know,
last time I was at home,
you were at home,
and I kept thinking
there was light
at the end of the tunnel.
I still feel that.
-Yes.
-I still feel that
because nobody, Seth --
nobody wants to go back
to the way it was.
-No.
-We're not going back
to the way it was.
-We will not go back
-No.
-And I think one of --
You know, I remember
last year around this time,
it sort of dawned on
I think a lot of us --
"Oh, maybe I won't travel
for the holidays.
Maybe I'm not gonna see my
family for Thanksgiving."
And it does feel
a little bit more optimistic
in regards to that this year,
and it's really nice to have --
I can't believe this is the
25th year of Favorite Things.
-You know,
this started 25 years ago,
so just think about Oprah
for a second.
So, it went from the magazine
to the TV show,
to now we're on digital,
Oprah Daily.
It started 25 years ago
because somebody sent her
a pair of pajamas
that she liked.
-That was it.
-That was it. Karen Neuburger.
Because she liked Oprah.
She sent it.
And Oprah believes that life
is always better when shared.
Don't you think?
Always better when shared.
-Yes.
-So she decided that
she would give the pajamas away.
But anybody who makes
her Favorite Things list,
you had to agree to give it
to the whole studio audience.
It was 300-plus people.
That's how it started.
-And people agree--
I mean, I would assume
that's a pretty good trade.
-But you'd be surprised, Seth.
There are a couple of people
said, "No, we can't do that."
-Really?
-They shall remain nameless.
-Wow! Forever, by the way.
They're out of business.
-I really do want to tell you
because I'm like, "What?!"
-Did you bring anything
for us this time?
-Yes, because, Seth,
I'm so nuts about you.
-Thank you.
-I love your wife, Alexi.
He's got two adorable boys.
-Mm-hmm.
-Ashe and Axel.
-That's it.
-Okay, so, the list --
Can I just say something
about the list?
Over 110 items.
It's the biggest list
we've ever had.
We decided to focus
on women business,
business of people of color,
and small businesses.
-That's businesses
run by babies.
-Business -- Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
So, this is --
Oh, I should've let you open it.
This is The Honest Company
from Jessica Alba.
-Oh, my God. Oh, yeah.
We love Jessica Alba.
-Don't we love her?
-Yeah. These are great.
-Aren't these cute, guys?
-Very cute.
-So we got a set for you...
-Okay.
-...for your lovely wife,
and for your two sons
and for Frisbee,
there's a matching bandana.
-Really?!
-[ Audience awws ]
-Isn't that good?
I think so, too.
You guys are a good audience.
I like that.
-So, you got my boys
two different colors.
-Yes.
-Which means they're going to
tear the [bleep]
apartment apart.
-But you can [bleep] afford
to fix it.
-Sold!
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, and...
-Oh, this is -- All right.
-This -- I really like this.
-Oh, my gosh.
-And you better bleep that out.
Otherwise, I won't have a job.
-I will. I will.
-Okay. So --
-I don't think my wife
is going to wear it.
[ Laughter ]
-Seth, do we dare ask audience
what goes on at his house?
That he pulls out a dog leash...
[ Laughter ]
-Now we're gonna have to
edit that out.
-I'm going to tell Alexi.
Okay.
So, this is from Foggy Dog.
I think this is cool.
A bandana, a leash,
and for the doody bags.
-Oh, great.
-'Cause I know
you clean up the poop.
-Of course. Absolutely.
-I know you do.
-Even when -- when I'm at work,
they call,
and I go all the way back.
This is a bandana for Frisbee?
-It's for Frisbee.
-Gorgeous.
-So Frisbee we got two things.
-That's really nice.
-So then I thought this.
Because the list goes from $13,
which is eye-makeup palette,
all the way over to $2,000,
which is a rower.
I didn't bring the rower,
but I did bring you...
-Ooh.
-♪ Da-da-da-da ♪
When you're all dressed
in your matching jammies.
-This is very lovely.
-Eastern Standard waffles.
-Okay.
-So it comes with --
Isn't that good?
It comes -- All you have to
do -- Put in the oven.
You got several
different toppings.
Caramel, my favorite.
Fudge, strawberry.
-And we --
Actually this is really nice.
'Cause we're gonna have
a little there, yeah.
So, um --
-Here it is.
-So, that's caramel sauce.
And that's dark fudge sauce.
Great.
And this won't make a mess
or anything.
And we can just have
a conversation.
-I come bringing gifts
for you, Seth.
-It's very nice. I am --
-I do.
I got you this pencil.
-Oh. [ Laughs ]
Gosh. For my very own?
-It's your very own!
But you got something --
you got something --
A better gift than
I could ever give you this year.
-Ooh, yeah.
-You had a grandson.
-I'm so excited about this.
I have a grandson.
I am somebody's grandmother.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, I don't know which --
I will start with this.
This is a very --
This is a very cute photo.
-Yes, yes, yes. This is me
and favorite daughter, Kirby.
Now favorite grandson, Luca.
And this is Slater.
Everybody has to color
coordinate our outfits.
But there really is something.
You know,
I remember my grandmother.
She seemed a little old.
And I don't feel old at all.
There's something about
seeing your own child
become a parent that I don't
even know how to explain.
Listen, I'm not the first person
that has a grandchild. I get it.
But, God, once it happens
to you, it's like --
I want to show you
all the pictures.
What else you got?
-I'm really happy with this one.
This is his Halloween costume.
Pillsbury Doughboy.
-What I like about this
is my kids are now the age
where you put them
in their Halloween costume,
and all it is,
when you take the photo --
They're at the age where
you're like, "Smile, smile,"
and trying to get both of them
to smile at the same time
is an impossibility.
Whereas this is such a fun age
'cause all you have to worry
about is just propping them.
-No. That's true.
And that's what we did.
We propped him.
And then the hand came out,
and you take the picture.
That's exactly right.
Lesley Stahl did a book
about grandparents,
and we had her on and I read it,
and I thought,
"This is a very lovely book,"
but now I want to go back
and read it again.
-Yeah.
-Because I think it'll have
a totally different meaning.
May we all feel the love
that we all feel for this child.
Honest to God.
-So, my parents sometimes feel
as though we are too strict.
The parents, you know?
We're too strict to them
insofar as how they treat
the kid and what they do.
Have you gotten in trouble
with your daughter yet?
-Well, it's funny
you should say that.
Funny you should say that.
Because I took a picture
of Luca.
Do you have it?
-I think we have this one.
It's this one, right? She had
an issue with this photo.
-She had an issue.
-By the way, I want to note...
I think Luca did, too.
-But here was the issue.
Because I was "babysitting."
Listen. Luca is
only seven weeks old.
They live in L.A.
I've been to L.A.
five out of the seven weeks.
You think they're tired
of seeing me?
"Kirby and Virgil,
can I please come over?"
Listen, I try to follow
their instructions.
-Yeah.
-So I just thought
that would be a cute picture,
and she came home and she said,
"You know,
you didn't put him in properly."
I said, "Kirby, I just put him
in to take the picture."
She said,
"Well, we don't do that.
If you're going to do it, we
like that he's put in properly."
I said, "But I was
just taking a picture."
"Doesn't matter.
He has to be put in properly."
So listen. I'm gonna follow
all the instructions.
I'm trying not to be that guy,
but it's very --
You know, I raised two children.
-You don't want
to be the first grandmother
to have a restraining order.
-Seth, I raised two children.
I think I did okay.
But listen.
It is a note to self.
You have to take your lead
from them.
-Yes.
-You do have to take --
-Hey, what do your kids
call your mom and your dad?
-Oh, that's
a very good question.
-'Cause I don't want to
be called Grandma or Nana.
-We had a jackpot because
my parents talked so long about
what they wanted to be called,
and it was idiotic.
Like, my mom was like,
"I think I want to be Mew Mew
because my grandmother
was Swedish."
And it's, like, the first
I'm hearing of it.
I'm like, "You're not going to
be Mew Mew. What are you talk--"
-I've met your mom.
She's lovely.
-She is lovely. But they
were approaching this wrong.
Then my oldest, the first time
he said, "Grandpa,"
he pronounced it "Ponka,"
And so we call --
My parents are the Ponkas.
-See? I like that. I like that.
-And they're Larry and Hillary,
and so they're Ponka-arry
and Ponka-hury.
And it's perfect.
And they're growing.
It's absolutely --
It's organic and natural.
And so I like that you're trying
to decide what
you're going to be called,
but I think
you've got to let them --
-Yeah, people keep saying
they'll make up their own name.
But I have had some suggestions,
Seth.
-Do you get suggestions
from you-know-who?
-Well, the suggestion
I have for myself is Gaia,
which, by the way, guys,
means "Mother Earth."
And it kind of sounds
like "Gayle."
But I don't want to be called
Gail by my grandchild.
So I came up with Gaia,
which I thought was very nice.
Oprah. You all know her.
-Yeah.
-She suggested Oprah.
-She --
[ Laughter ]
That's good.
Well, she's very opinionated.
She said, "Gaia.
That sounds pretentious."
Do you guys think
it sounds pretentious?
-Kinda?
-It's a little --
It's a little pretentious.
-Do you think so?
See? Oh, Seth.
God, you're hurting me.
And then Kirby said,
favorite daughter Kirby said,
"Mom, that's very extra."
So, I had said Gaia.
I was walking down the street
on 8th Avenue,
and a woman walked up to me,
and she said,
"I don't know
what's wrong with you.
I hear you want
to be called..."
She said, "Gai-anne or whatever
you want to call yourself."
What's wrong with Grandma?"
And then she just turned around
and walked off.
But the way she said,
"Gai-anne or whatever
you want to call yourself.
That don't even make no sense.
What's wrong with Grandma?"
And then she just walked off.
"Thank you, ma'am.
It's so nice to meet you."
Wait a second, Seth. I'm being
very serious about that.
You think it sounds pretentious?
-I think "Gaia" --
I think the fact that "Gaia"
means "Mother Earth"
is the problem with it.
-But, Seth, that's what --
-I would go with, like, GoGo.
Like, just have --
Like, it shouldn't
have a meaning.
-But, Seth, I thought that
that was endearing.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Guys, don't encourage him!
Don't encourage him.
-If you leave
with anything today,
it's this --
you can't win 'em all.
-Okay. No. Maybe I'll be --
What is it? Ponka?
-Ponka. Ponka.
We want Ponka to take off.
Ponka Gayle.
-Okay. Ponka. All right.
-All right.
I have a -- I want to give you
one last opportunity.
I want to make up for the fact
that I have not supported you
on Gaia.
-Yes.
-Taylor Swift is coming here
tomorrow.
-Tomorrow. Do you know
how much I like Taylor Swift?
-I do know how much you like.
-I've been to four
of Taylor's concerts.
I really like her.
When she was sending out
those cardigan sweaters,
did you get one? I did.
-I did not.
-I did.
-Point, Gaia.
-Oh, but I like her
so much love.
-She's lovely. But I want to
give you the opportunity.
-She's here tomorrow.
And I'm here today.
-You're here today.
-Thanks, Seth.
-You're welcome.
-Thanks, Mike. Thanks. Thanks.
But I'm really glad to see you.
-But you want to -- I wanted
to give you the opportunity
to leave something for Taylor.
-Okay.
This is what I was thinking.
Because you like
the pajamas so much.
I actually have
a matching pair, too.
-Okay. I think
it's on the other side of you.
-Where is it?
-On the other side.
Right over there.
-Okay. Good.
So, I thought when she comes --
And, Seth, I would like
an on-camera presentation.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-You guys know
that's not happening.
I would like
an on-camera presentation
to say Gayle was here yesterday
and she brought this for you.
And so I thought
it would be nice for her
to have a pair of pajamas
like you have and I have.
Then we could all come over
to your place.
-Okay.
-Me and Taylor.
-I mean, it sounds good.
-For breakfast.
-I'm just -- I don't want you
to ever say that I lied to you.
So I'm going to tell you now
I will tell her
it's from both of us.
-Okay. Fair enough.
-Gaia King, everybody!
Mother Earth!
The winter issue of
"O Quarterly" is on stands now.
And Oprah's Favorite Things
are also available
at OprahDaily.com and Amazon.